what would it mean if this show filled
the Ozark shaped hole that people had in
their viewing habits well it would make
sense because it's also based on a on a
on a place in the country
maybe would it feel good we feel nice if
people love it the same way that they
love those are well sure my God I mean
we should only be so lucky that's right
there are also a bunch of incredibly
talented people on this show like we
were lucky to have on Ozark so it
wouldn't it wouldn't surprise me uh this
is a pretty cool thing they put together
I bring her back I walk away clean
forever my entire death
fine what's Jason like as a boss like a
mob boss or a real light touch do you
well yeah I mean does anybody really
need a boss I mean if you hire correctly
people know what they're doing and they
don't need to be told what to do or you
know encouraged to do what they do they
do what they do because they want to do
it right so you just try to find the
right uh the right set of ingredients
and kind of let it cook itself what are
three words that describe Florida that
also describe this show oddly shaped
Southern and
um origin and unpredictable I like it I
like those been listening to smartless I
love the Revelation that you guys are in
a Wordle nerdle League am I getting that
right you I've been told not to talk
about that anymore you guys let the cat
out of the bag and now you gotta shut it
back down
I I I I didn't someone else did and it's
uh now it's like oh does it exist or
does it not exist now we don't even know
you gotta open it up to the public and
get another Revenue stream in there play
Wordle with the boys yeah we'll charge a
little like 9.99 hook it up to giraffe
Kings or something
[Music]